the Joe Rogan experience no ma'am
what would you do listen to old stuff
yeah listen to I like we I do like 90s
R&B now I like funk music I like like
Bootsy Collins alright
I love Jimi Hendrix he's one of my
favorites I like Curtis Mayfield Marvin
Gaye frickin cool in the game [ __ ] I
listen to everything bright I like a lot
of the older soul music like The
Spinners Patti LaBelle you know I'm
sampling I was raised on everything my
dad listen to Bob Marley he listened the
freakin oh he's listened to a lot of
sting in the police really yeah I love
staying he's one of my favorites just
all the jams you know what I'm saying
like the classic [ __ ] like you could put
on any song like for real for real and I
[ __ ] with it because I listen to a lot
of different music and yeah I mean
Marvin Gaye man yeah he's one of my
favorite he was phenomenal yeah Marvin
Gaye was really good and this is tragic
story that was crazy
his dad shot him it's so crazy I I dated
a girl once his girl was so nuts
mm-hm and I we were talking about shot
okay no no we were talking about Marvin
Gaye you know saying that's like it's so
insane that his dad shot him and she
said imagine what a piece of [ __ ] he had
to be for his dad to shoot him Yeah
right
and I was like what no no no no no no no
why would you assume he's the beseech it
was dad [ __ ] shot if he's a piece of
[ __ ] why does his dad just get away from
that's shooting him his dad's a piece of
[ __ ] like but it was amazing she was
like instantly thinking he's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah like I'm like I don't get your
logic it's really good she's someone who
grew up with a good she's still loved
her down she was close with her dad yeah
so I was like God I don't know my dad so
doesn't to me I'm like that dad shot him
he was Marvin Gaye mmm he's probably
upset that his son had become Marvin
Gaye truth they imagined being Marvin
Gaye - we all your songs are like the
best music - [ __ ] - yeah and he didn't
have there was nothing there was no
slide into the dm's now they had to find
him physically yep but he seemed like
kind of like a faithful guy like he
seemed like he would find like one shake
yeah just [ __ ] her right album about it
that would be a good narrative mm-hmm I
think it's hard for those dudes if
they're singing about [ __ ] all the
time it's coming their way
no they usually like just wanna [ __ ] one
girl like that right those those love
songs yeah exactly when the music's dark
like easy either
you mean they he's [ __ ] mad [ __ ] he
wasn't like just one right he was known
as Marvin Gaye [ __ ] that was all I
remember he said sexual healing I mean
when you get that feeling he needs
sexual healing the [ __ ] made him feel
better yeah when he was with her that's
a big difference between the nwaz first
album sexually there's some [ __ ] from
like the early gangster rap days you
listen to today like whoa yeah yeah this
is this is crazy stuff mmm I remember it
at the time when it was first coming out
mm-hmm and no one knew what like no one
could understand there was no music like
this before and then all sudden you have
iced tea yeah that was before it ate
what the frickin parental advisory on
there they made that because like
there's like your parents make sure
y'all check this out before your kids
get it it was Al Gore's wife it was
tipper gore
mm-hmm it was she was the one who was in
charge it was like she was leading the
charge yeah against I think it was her
make sure I'm right about that is it I'm
not mad at that that may rap music
better you think so oh yeah it's like
made it more dangerous I'll be put to
the extreme yeah yeah these shoes they
were trying to irate at our movie
they're trying to ban some stuff though
they were trying to ban so he was
amusing like oh well that was Florida or
it is crazy don't [ __ ] around in Florida
they catch you in Florida
yeah they arrest people for anything you
can get arrested for obscenity in for
I'm
I'm good not going in Florida Florida
was a go but I'm not going crazy in
Florida yeah
briar County here yeah just don't get
arrested for swearing yeah that's what
they got to Live Crew for explicit
lyrics yeah [ __ ] I'm good or not forget
about that right yeah those guys would
like to Lenny Bruce of rap right like
Lenny Bruce's a guy I want to get
arrested a bunch of times for stand-up
comedy he wouldn't change his words and
you know swearing on stage for the court
that was 2 Live Crew now you're going to
jail for like for rap yeah that's crazy
it's crazy for saying some for saying
something somebody doesn't like it so
they want to put you in a cage Wow cuz
they don't like how you're saying wow
they don't like what you're saying they
don't like how you're saying it like
could you arrest someone if they just
said that somewhere what if they're in
the comfort of their own house mm-hmm
and they said the things that are in
that mm-hmm
is that illegal yeah did you yell it out
the window yeah could I Drive down the
road yelling it out the window right I
should be able to it should be able to
[ __ ] are you to tell people they can't
do that
but then Florida they're like nope
obscenity rap Florida's like its own
world don't like that's why when [ __ ]
goes down it's like iron in his Florida
[Applause]